ciao ragazzi bentornati a una puntata di
cucina buttata un pochino di tempo fa
abbiamo provato la carbonara francese
abbiamo preso un piatto italiano abbiamo
visto come lo facevano come lo
distruggevano all'estero sono arrivati
tanti commenti alcuni divertiti altri di
odio motivato altri anche un po meno
ragazzi e alla fine ci siamo detti sì ok
noi siamo romani forse prima di provare
a carbonara francese avremmo dovuto
spiegare come si fa la carbonara ora
parte dal presupposto che esistono un
sacco di varianti credo che questa
versione non l'ho mai fatta in vita mia
ci sono un sacco di questi di pancetta
con cialde cipolla non cipolla quante
uova all'album esile album e no è
arrivato il momento di spiegare come
viene fatta senza giudizio ragazzi
perché un calcolato n matera fa col
prezzemolo delle buonissime
ma non è una carbonara per fare la
carbonara avrete bisogno di anno abbiamo
già sbagliato la pasta tonnarelli o
rigatoni a seconda di pasta lunga o
pasta corta ma non abbiamo trovato nei
tonarelli né rigatoni quindi abbiamo
fatti gli spaghetti alla chitarra va
bene gli spaghetti alla chitarra perché
sono un pochino grossi un po corposi né
una pasta all'uovo o riga cioè uova
pecorino il pecorino migliore sarebbe
teoricamente quello nero culo romano ne
abbiamo trovato quello di amatrice e
comunque nei [ __ ] guanciale non
pancetta non bacon non quella pancia le
guanciale sacro soprattutto guanciale
amatriciana l'amatriciana ma se non fa
la matriciana noi
vabbè ok e infine pepe nero in alcuni
ristoranti dove sono stato specialmente
a milano la carbonara a volte la servono
con uovo pancetta e senza pepe sola
calmo lavia
non io l'ho vista mangiare io mi prendo
la gara milano è una cosa buona e
orecchie d'elefante comunque non so
parlato di quello ragazzi è
importantissimo la carbonara si chiama
che co di cosa state parlando
dunque sì ma non è un orecchio delle
fango ma tu pensavi che fosse un
orecchio le orecchie d'elefante la
cotoletta na che si chiama orecchie
d'elefante perché largamente orecchie
delle fanta perché a milano mangiano
orecchie di elefanti non è una cotoletta
e come tina pasta con l'uomo
se avete i commenti di odio non per me
ma per gian marco pepe nero ragazzi è
fondamentale mettere il pepe nero
all'interno della carbonara altrimenti
perché dovrebbe chiamarsi carbonara
carbone perché la riempì di pepe nero
così tanto che sembra quasi carbonizzata
ora io magari esagera questo certo
perché la mangiano i carbonari si si io
mi informerei questa forse ho detto una
cazzata
vabbè andiamo avanti metteteci il pepe
io nel frattempo ho già messo l'acqua
sul fuoco perché in realtà la carbonara
una pasta veramente veloce è un passo
importante è il sale nell'acqua non
mettete viene troppo perché lamenta che
abbiamo il guanciale il pecorino già
sarà abbastanza salata e poi soprattutto
nel momento in cui utilizzeremo l'acqua
di cottura per fare la cremina rischiamo
veramente che ci partano i reni
incominciamo mettiamo
non esagerare 103 non mi trovo quintale
non è vero hai già smentito finire
all'inferno
partiamo subito con il guanciale lo
tiriamo fuori prima cosa devo fare è
eliminare la cotenna tipo il nostro
amico chef barbato la utilizza per
soffriggerla insieme al guanciale lo
facciamo ma poi sia barbato non lo
criticherei mai il nostro collega aka
king raniolo non ce la facciamo mai
possibile come lo possa indossare in
maniera divertente evidente una cosa
importantissima quando si taglia e
guanciale il verso in cui si affetta noi
stiamo mettendo troppo ma perché il
concentramento troppo e poi bisogna
tagliarlo in questo senso
vedete le listarelle devono essere così
si vabbè volevo farlo vedere
tranne quella sopra è in realtà sono
spezia occhio c'è parma tolosa
mamma mia non ti convince a voi la
tenente la parte nera oppure no oddio
stiamo già iniziando con questo siamo
già arrivati a questo punto calcolate
che mi madre la fa con la pancetta le
uova intere prezzemolo ma con molto
amore bolla la cipolla la cipolle vero
cioè sto parlando con umiltà comunque
ragazzina che vi sto dicendo anche degli
sfigati se non la fate così vai stiamo
attendendo la cappa cotenne sul fuoco
tra la pancetta ne stiamo usando un
botto è bacchetta diego no niente olio
miano si mette pure l'olio mentre nel
frattempo il guanciale sfrigola
prendiamo il pecorino ti preferivo
quando quando non c'eri l'ho pagato un
po grandino forse dovuto farlo ancora
più sottile però così se facciamo
proprio il borsone la sto facendo male
ma posso dirvi solo una cosa secondo me
all'inferno c'è un girone dove devono
fare questo tutto il tempo
se non è una tortura
nel frattempo passiamo alla questione
nuova ci sono varie scuole di pensiero
noi stiamo per mettere 500 grammi di
pasta siamo in tre si dice un uovo più
un nuovo a testa siamo tre io metto un
tuorlo ogni 100 solo i tuorli c'è anche
chi la fa con l'album è che forse quella
più
prendiamo le uova sbarchiamo un pochino
mamma mia quanto so daltonico mi
sembrano verdi alcuni pezzi
a me sembra verde a te sembra verde
aggiungiamo il pecorino e ora dovremo
creare una pasta mettiamo la pasta
non pensate le il guanciale diventerà
croccantissima e come vedete non serve
l'olio oggi voglio fare il figo voglio
far vedere che non sono semplicemente
una bomba sexy messa davanti a dei
fornelli non dovrebbe aver paura se è
pastosi no perché è normale della
allungate con l'acqua di cottura che non
dovete buttare è sempre un po un sacro
graal prezioso molte persone pensano che
diluisca ma in realtà il glutine per te
presenti all'interno della pasta aiuta a
creare la cremina quindi se siete
fondamentalmente
si siede ciliaci la pasta ce l'avete
sempre un po allungata credo non so
magari una cazzata che dico caro dette
poche prendiamo il pepe intanto mentre
enrico cerca il piatto ne mettiamo un po
dentro già al intingolo nei piatti non
ci sono sì come fai a vivere con tre
piatti via fra ragazzi prendiamo altri
due piatti e così se avete già il vostro
piatto fatto
cioè stiamo cercando obiettivo ok
abbiamo l'altro piatto di enrico non va
bene
questo quello nero ok prendiamo acqua di
cottura e l'aver siamo qua dentro una
messa troppa troppo liquido ragazzi
una cosa buona nell'acqua di cottura non
cuoce l'uovo mallo pastorizza sto
sbagliando tutto spegniamo il fuoco e
aggiungiamo l'uomo
sì sì
e se sì
sì
vi farò due impiatta menti per quello
chic avremmo bisogno di un coppapasta
per me
la carbonara riposata a cagare
vi prego possiamo sentire sto coso era
lui mi sta mettendo ansia spruzzata di
pecorino messa sopra
[Musica]
ok velocemente vi faccio vedere invece
un impiatta mento alla romana non
richiede un coppapasta richiede
semplicemente molta fretta
eccolo qui fare un impianto detto alla
romana poi mentre una persona cerca di
già strapparvi il piatto con una mano le
dovete tenere il polso
aspetta un secondo e in quei pochi
secondi in cui lui avvicinerà il piatto
alla sua cosa dovete velocemente crearli
hanno tutto quanto prima che lui prenda
il piatto per sé infine abbiamo
l'incartamento alla enrico è un pochino
più complicato praticamente tu hai
allora aspetto al secondo ci sta non è
giusto quindi questo possiamo darla al
gatto è questo qui di enrico e direi che
arrivato il momento di assaggiare belle
di pecorino per guardare il piatto alla
bocca ecco veloce veloce veloce ottimo
miniti 8 ott io ho messo un po a roma
per facciamo l'assaggio buonissima
una carbonara mamma è divina ragazzine
stiamo morendo di fame
finiremo questi piatti saranno pure il
nostro pranzo come sempre taka temi su
instagram se cercherete di fare anche
voi la carbonara diciamo nella maniera
più originale possibile
fatemi sapere qua sotto in realtà se
siete romani e conoscete magari delle
varianti ufficiali o se non siete romani
e conoscete le varianti non ufficiali ma
che comunque sono buone che dire noi ci
vediamo sempre la prossima domenica a
mezzogiorno ciao
comunque posso dire la cosa come che
sarà